[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
happy Friday and welcome to legates
must-read we are streaming the
up-and-coming jack box party pack 4
comes out
starting on the 19th I believe the 18th
actually and rolls out it says it's
rolling out across different platforms
all next week until the 20th that's
gonna be switch it's gonna be
PlayStation and Xbox okay we're gonna
take a look at this awesome awesome
party game if you're familiar with it
you got to use your phone and
participate in a variety of bizarre ass
games and you to which you're watching
and join as an audience participator or
sour this is a word a participator
happened parts us participate
participate but let's get right to it so
the person we're gonna do is pivot
three-way make sure we can get into the
game before anybody else does right cuz
they're gonna see the code name correct
and there and well they're gonna cut
away assuming everyone doesn't just like
auto join okay um so let's I'm digging
this music yeah it's it's cool it's
there's some weird categories when we
turn polling Oh Soph image is one that
they've had in obviously just heard of
them they've had this an almost every
other party pack this is one of my
favorites
yes I'm glad they keep bringing this one
back okay John Luke you're gonna want to
cut away super quick alright yeah let's
do it
that's our code
loading loading okay are you nice why
all right oven rubs on it we get so for
audience members can join we're out you
can pan okay we're getting Peter to if
you want we can so Joey and Callie in
the office are also gonna play or lose
this village see their Collier doing
okay so mom let's just kick it off now
wait let the other people fill up well
we're missing Joey or Callie one of them
and then unless that's bone right there
are you guys all filing in what's doing
Kim be on TV what do is uh Mike you are
the VIP so you kick it off claims so
yeah apparently this is the biggest of
the Jack Fox packs with five games
welcome to my parlor I'm cookie
Masterson but here you can call me mr.
Applewhite eight players that's enough
to field an official Korff ball team and
yet you chose to play this game I thank
you and anybody watching can join the
audience any time the audience votes on
fake answers to fool those gullible
players and they also get to guess the
truth let's do this summer of love
with your made-up answer manual met a
thousand for finding the truth time to
pick a category exm whoever's on the
flag right question one Virginia is the
only u.s. state whose flag features
blank now on your device take that a
good lie they can think other players my
heart what are the odds of this video
does not become NSFW oh so have you best
I'm allowed to get a little wild with
this right yes try to be your you're
trying to get people to pick your lawyer
for your fibbing obviously
[Music]
but I knew
just as well little-known fact for our
viewers
Justin probably is the dirtiest image
player there is a disabled Justin over
you may not look it that's not
necessarily true
you have to change it up you have to be
able to just go straight in for it oh
this is the danger we going with
audience members this is gonna get worse
good good I think good and give soon
give some props to somebody's you're
just joining us for playing the new jack
box party pack 4 comes out next week
how's it going oh good job audience ok
right
Calvin's mine she oh that's good
chalice it's like stately Oh a bird huh
ha ha got to you ah so original a bird
it's perfect give me those pulse right
Oh what was it that's what I guess yeah
that's the truth isn't it nudity you
know I know that I think Lee the
California state flag has a nude bear
there we go so I feel like I want to
hear my winning well yeah the Bears not
wearing pants I don't know how many whoa
ok all right shoes round celebrity
tweets in May 2014
Martha Stewart tweeted a picture of a
cow and wrote blank take our lives now
yes it has to be exactly that face so
this can be long cannon
[Music]
hurry use the life of me button if
you're stuck why for me there's a
clarify this is pretty much just more
fitted oh nothing different about this
except for the style what I don't know
honestly yeah nope machine is good like
no machine shoot this one damn it good
job cuz that seemed like a normal answer
yeah this is the truth isn't it
no Kimbrough Zack what me oh she would
write that's so innocuous oh you know
what I do then see that cow you're like
whoa she just accidentally typed this
dang it she's my god if you don't get
Martha
that's on you he was gonna miss was it a
typo
so how do i tweet
oh no no cliche it's an uncommon classic
Martha's bizarre corpse czar clubs or
clubs okay focus up according to some
historians composers Bach and Handel
were both blank by the same man all
right typing your lies
I'm at the point now where I could
decide if I want to try to win or just
go off the rounds officer restless but I
actually got enough points that's where
he's a bit of a Mike
hurry get the light getting really about
this the answer spawn if you're just
joining us you're welcome
this is Jack box party pack - oh God
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah it wasn't Goodwin Hawkins
they weren't flying at old famous oh
they were asking a [ __ ] that actually
sounds what such a nice one damn it's
funny it's a funny one
Oh
oh wow good one too
it's probably it though they weren't
shot I don't know you could be shot not
digested the person ate I think it's a
person named no damn is it kissed its
kiss not your finest effort they're
blind John Taylor was an eye doctor
luckily none of his patients could read
the fine print
oh dang yeah Danny wonder who wrote like
this I wonder who wrote cast huh
it says it right here you got 3 likes
get ready for us points are doubled the
score getting games always bothered me
like the first round the ringling matter
boo mobster nicknames come on more
really I really like the 2012 boring
Oregon became sister cities with a town
in Scotland named it blank answer your
lies now what if this announcer sounds
like the exact same in real life that's
how he talks I think I'm going to
McDonald's today
I'll be there in six Finnish Brant
Oregon just hit the live for me buddy
[Music]
[Music]
that's why I'm not going all out okay
which one is the truth holding back
Oh flaccid that's a good one
as people keep trying to join the room
to keep calm in an error room is full
but he walked out no I'm fine identities
count
[Applause]
to get in the pan big fan big gonna
blasted and horn bleary I was thinking
about picking now on to get that's a
good line no one was godly because it
sounds kind of like a Scottish word yeah
[Music]
you know what fundal Scotland because
that was my yeah come on give it to me
[Music]
you can't look at the answers I have
became sister cities with cocaine island
exactly just curious work you're worse
behind a lot of Jessica's pronounced
black CID Mikey gangster names ganks to
make noodles come on stir something
looks my place wise not letting means
you can't be bothered
yeah okay well pick monster nicknames
okay
you can get to pick California mobster
cheero Terranova was a terror in the
early 1900s the audience be intimidated
if you knew his nickname was the blank
King oh yeah
[Music]
because I'm a mobster so this one is
better
welcome to the audience would you like
an office I should have waited
[Music]
so all right where's all coming all
right
[Laughter]
[Music]
so many good ones all right let's see
what everybody picked yeah hi there
Brian it's a sweet one the smiling cake
it's San Francisco oh yeah was a good
life yummy don't
[Music]
oh man really Chia how good that was
that I don't know tell me has the word
choke in it how do you pick cigar
because I was gonna do so it's gonna put
cigar it was too phallic without
actually being Mike with a solid bed
there
dude you are falling behind what
happened did you get caught Sebastian
says play the new games we will we just
want to get this one out of the way
hang in there baby school baby school
it's a shape up shape up or she can pass
him David Lloyd clubs abilities fitness
class in 2017 to their sick couple under
location to get in shape people spent 45
minutes blank right your lives now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what does this game says trike this is a
game called box jet box party packed
forward to series of games that you play
on your phone and you can't - in the top
left there this is one of five games
there's a reoccurring one but the other
ones are new we're gonna take a look
after this they are raising computers
because like baby commuters little
phones
- yeah use your phones this this is a
game where we try to love this part
fill in a fake answer and have everyone
picking more people pick your kid that
was a good one
damn that was so good it was also oh
damn was good oh you answer no our means
good jobs our clocks and
doesn't give anything that didn't seem
way too
I hear you bury colonies pretty pretty
often you eat celery giving pleasure you
don't say
[Music]
I give up something waifu you know I
think one what nice I spend eight hours
every day asleep right
maybe they like when you're asleep they
like no stretches like for you like they
like knock you out any stretches right
come through yet
thank God doesn't say if I lose to Mike
who hasn't played around really good
kick started me in Japanese mythology
there are monsters called Papa who are
always trying to steal the chouriço
Dhamma which is a blank blank you
probably know a tree into your lives
it's a picket one
[Music]
okay take a look and find the truth I
actually don't know what it [ __ ] : oh
my god it just picking poop I know and I
know we really wanted that one full of
it is it taking proof it is I doubt it's
magic oh my god it isn't a Dhamma
Aldama is like a ball o GD o GD well
chibi is is how you say ass that is how
you say [ __ ] you're kidding me right
I shot cops Congrats
that's played every game I just lost to
someone that wasn't playing man yeah
just don't get my Shimura that's it and
we learned a little bit of Japanese I
forgot that the work for a school maybe
you did shitty
don't be an ocean most goggle great
alright we don't see this I got a trophy
when I get a trophy for losing votes
we're slaughter all right let's try is
these new ones a couple of them look
pretty great there looks sort of the
last game at the TKO the eyes are just
yeah there's something similar like that
and love that y'all I'm just connected
oh we're so sweet
yeah let's known chat with your favorite
jackpots survive what Internet's so this
is what we we like rearrange people's
you can cut away probably right we will
in a second oh thank you
[Music]
here let me go
[Music]
music's pretty little slow house good 75
[Music]
who's the bit oh hey that's not nice you
guys read right yeah hey alright you go
away
Joey's planes that reminds me of that
western film The Shootist don't forget
you can join the audience a and it's not
hard to get that comic we do anything we
can break the Internet ya know it
generally happens every time I play who
is Robin cookie Masterson is what was in
the Internet
this place is huge did you know it has
over 1,000 sites let me show you around
in case you need some instructions check
out this quick tutorial hey guys what's
up
party boy 7 here to teach you how to
play survive the internet so in each
round you'll get a prompt on your device
go ahead and answer it those responses
will then be sent to another player the
objective is to twist these words in the
most ridiculous way possible so if my
friend Paul said selfie sticks are quote
super dumb then I would take him out of
context they were on a news site they're
super dumb would be an outrageous
comment to what headline oh I got it ok
that's it thanks for watching please
like and subscribe please I feel so
empty inside let's start things off that
uh crowdfunding sounds nice
so you should be seeing a prompt on your
controller there are no wrong answers so
just answer honestly
[Music]
that's gonna be pretty good I might join
the audience's treichel you know this is
late the top right UV y j go to jack box
got TV / well that's it and then you'll
and then you'll you'll see we're down to
the code and enter your name you're
getting another player's answer on your
device take these words off in the most
ridiculous way you can
[Music]
[Music]
so it's a question right
I think is it one's different
[Music]
[Music]
it sounds cool this does remind me of
TKO it's the only difference really is
just drawing I do have to draw on the
t-shirts
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mr. trip - hey
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay I got it
but what do we pick the funniest one or
is there another love them that step
that we haven't done this we will find
out Oh
I got it now
okay I didn't get mine investment so I
don't vote for the comment you think
looks the worst in this context I know
[Music]
just announced new going around that the
two cents
okay here the way but we're voting for
the and here's how the audience felt yes
say you know I'm nodding
and here the victim get some pity points
like that thing Bill O'Reilly's funny
but it doesn't feel like it yeah I can
see like what's the key it's not
supposed to they said who looks the most
ridiculous yeah it was different so
everyone got different things yeah I
thought I was looking at what the person
wrote everyone's doing why are you
looking at Noah we like it's the now
it's the campaign right now they said
the question was who looks the most
ridiculous so he looked really great
videos eight
your second prompt is being sent to your
device please answer it
[Music]
[Music]
so I get points if people pick your
thing but also if people pick right in
the thing that they write about whatever
the video said you're gonna be I guess
that's true I guess for TKO you got
points if you were the drawing and then
you were the text you get the most
points for actually combining yeah right
here's your clay now mold it into
something
[Music]
[Music]
take me down for them yeah I think I
could so for those of you who are glance
that don't really get what's going on
each one of us and other people who are
playing basically just respond to any
question by all to say what mine was
mine was like what's your experience
with hotels I said never walk around
barefoot and you send it and then now we
are arranging with like a new caption
here we go yeah so now it's like what's
the name of the video this would be the
good comment for this video write a
comment on a video exactly
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
oh my starts
Oh God literally just got to be kidding
oh man that's Kali by the way that's
Kali yeah see what that round does oh
[Music]
[ __ ] she's killing us oh yeah
I'm dead last let's switch things up go
to think I'm sitting here with a job
network I'm safe yeah early in the
backroom whatever what was that is that
what is that is that Satan as the
headlines family installers there are me
I'd like you to really listen to your
heart this time Oh God
[Music]
so this frame of reference mine says why
was God he's so great I'm typing
something mine says I don't think how
would you briefly describe Harry Potter
to someone I gotta say that the AIDS was
and now I have to wear pants that that
was clever where Rose dot thank you you
wrote that that was lace the Cabaret
Agnes I missed the category what was it
Satan I don't know some kind of job
Network I don't know what the Kepler job
networking job job
come on baby let's do the twist okay
[Music]
[Music]
now as I guess what reminder take
insulin if you need it also this is a
really old school looking desktop it's
like Windows 98 what's the house like
joking that this is like the beginning
Internet now that's the browser I use
you guys take so long to do everything
I'm sorry I'm sorry
hey you knuckleheads here we go I'm not
too happy much
[Music]
oh my god what what are the points I
think right that's a male lots of male
porn star I'm alright oh whoops I didn't
get the point of this I wasn't paying
attention
what's the job networking part so that
yeah
I think your system person exactly well
it says in the second it says in the
text box we should write oh yeah I just
realized that no it's fine right let's
get those boats in well
[Music]
yeah I didn't get this category right
either or I'm just tightening things or
not I mean I don't I don't necessarily
think it's like a good categories you
know I need I don't know none of these
were out yeah this was super fun
who is this who just dominated robbed it
won't me oh okay good post that was hard
I was starting that it's like how's it
going would be Hitler Stalin I've got to
go for a deeper cut I could have gotten
the guy in Florida it's aligned with
conjunct the scoreboard great cool
moving on up okay so whose [ __ ] Robin
who is the one in the back I mean
someone in the back alley this round
photo sharing site oh so now we're doing
photos or we're commonly at the Rose
I just I think it's gonna be a photo
minute yeah it's a photo now I pick a
dolphin I just got paid
hopefully make Callie look really dumb
[Music]
enemies not really what yeah welcome to
super hot enemies just nothing Oh
[Music]
or maybe Tacoma almost the kuboos kind
of like lines
I like the concept of this one now on
YouTube yeah I went really dark sure
Silva's not your attorney has led us to
this moment over the point of the first
thing to what you foul that's Mike so
someone that played said they'd rather
see stake I kind of get it like a beach
okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
I really really like the minivan one I
could see you posting that oh like 20
years yeah he's already got three kids
let's see how everybody voted yeah I got
some points
hiya Kelly are you pulling for being a
butt of the joke to move on that throbs
I wonder who won went up got third place
yeah Kelly is destroying us
what was the once at the first one she
got like an eleven hundred points on
[Music]
yeah sure let's call it she do another
one to everyone do a new game what's
done we can come back maybe for one more
depending on time even the bathrooms I
know but there's a bowl underneath
forgot my catheter don't dude knows
gross Michael say this floor is just
covered in pee it's disgusting
this is why I don't do the lobby let's
pee at monster seeking monster also this
is like a dating game
[Music]
we'll see wait I go first then you guys
can do it I'm gonna hide your secret
powers so like like the not a wolf
Twitter account if you're familiar also
can we uh sorry can we not kick my name
but now by saying that everyone's gonna
take my name yeah sure that was dumb
what did you say I don't know just so I
can like at least get an idea who people
are
[Music]
well we get to pick up polo there's a
TriCaster okey know you're also gonna
pick your care cool let's get let's see
yeah okay
oh sorry can't you hang tight I know
that
hang tight we playing jack box party
pack 4 comes out go ya go it comes out
next week different days different
platforms first one's gonna be ps4 and
then it's like Mac and PC and then
switch and then Xbox one Xbox one is
last yes switch I'm so happy to switch
as far as like bringing your switch like
I will be hosting six nights of booing
and booing where you'll try to convince
other players to go out with you by
sending them secret messages each night
you'll check with other players before
locking in the one person you want to
date that night the monster with the
most hearts wins if you put them to good
use let's all put oh man this is very
much like [ __ ] this is really death so
this is very much like well god I want
to say like clue it is yeah let's start
by chatting with other players and
trying to set up dates you can only fail
[Music]
damn I am like
[Music]
I'm just gonna read with mine should I
do that no cuz that's gonna ruin it
we're not gonna mind mind how many
people can i oh you have a limited
number of messages this I don't know if
this is great to stream is a riddle
secret conversation yeah
should we bounce out of this one
probably hope yeah we're gonna bounce it
seems like it could be fun but not first
streaming it's it's to like tell tell
them what you said just yeah so for
context what mine said was mmmm Joey is
my son you're you're getting like
details or like info on a person and
you're just trying to like you know
cater your cheer chat so I am Chad chat
with everyone else in the room so
anyways let's go over to the bounce out
this isn't work who was TriCaster opium
is that you don't move Oh rat rods go
figure I said hey how are you doing this
funny evening he just responds great
let's [ __ ] yeah unfortunately some says
dude dang that kind of sucks that seems
fun for the record it does seem really
fun but mindset so mine was very most I
start with a bonus heart and then if I
ask someone on a date and they reject me
they lose a heart so that's a kind of
Opie power I took to heart is whoever I
went on a second date with oh so you
don't want to go to something happen if
if like one of you or I think was Joey
if he loses too hard something
see I was as anyone who dated me became
a zombie and if anyone they dated would
also become a zombies like everyone
became zombie I want fun so you just
want to spread your I'm gonna suppress
my zombie vibrant kind of like real life
yeah your zombie or something Oh sci-fi
what's this one called racketeering wait
a second
well annual in the chat says this games
really good for streaming the audience
can join as a player everyone
collectively controls is one player this
one or racketeering monotheism and then
someone says next-gen says everyone sees
so the audience can see stuff yeah but
if they're just watching the stream and
not playing it they're not gonna see it
yeah
we'll ignore that okay let's cut away
for a sec house this won't work anyway
no no they haven't explained yet wow
this is cool
Tron action I suppose with the game up
we're gonna get Joey and gentlelady is
he not you know the first one in oh they
can see the game feed huh all right yeah
we're good everyone's in we're good spin
it all right oh yeah they're in the
bathroom so they can see we've got the
audience does play a little washed
through that closing some important
questions first interior devices now we
got in some content that plays in the
family friendly version type in the
answer you think has the best chance of
winning and hits and if your answer wins
the entire bracket you'll be rolling in
cash by the way you can join the
audience and play along by going to chat
box top TV and entering the room code
got it going on I think for the poopoo
platter your answers are being paired
off into one-on-one matchups that means
it's time to step up to the prediction
table on your device you'll see one of
the upcoming matchups for this bracket
if you can predict the answer that will
get the most votes you could win some
sizable bonus bucks the predictions are
in it's time to dive into our first you
can change your score in the middle a
dagger knows a hockey dingleberry
your answer isn't final you can switch
it yeah you can switch in the middle you
can that's pretty cool
Engelbert equal berries thank you
that's um dog race fans in here I think
so I didn't see any pleasure whoa Wow
what no heck in Tekken yeah but at the
last second you can switch you be doing
really confident about it's like a nice
I mean it's cool I'm not fighting it's
more for the audience people coming in
but it's not showing you who for this
week we have fudge verse dingleberry
[Music]
bonkers it sounds like bananas Walker
Wow get up close this is what happens in
a time Reebok
[Music]
we leave brick macdennis from sunny
whoopsy so Tom and a chat says you fools
you get to see everyone's messages is it
Tommy is a during laughs but if you're
part of the audience in the game like
people just watching the stream yeah
yeah that's what I'm curious about
so like the majority people watching
stream I don't how many people are
watching but before we give happening in
the game it's time to make another
prediction you've got a new matchup
waiting for you on your device predict
the one you think it's going to win the
predictions are in let's jump back to
our bracket for round two
things really close to know nothing baby
bears pulling have people like pick
fudge or I'm ending this stream I hide
it funder I did too alright audience
it's like that okay Wow I'm single very
so funny because if you go the finalists
I don't like this I love selecting March
Madness pit bulls
and I believe it's a much more fun it's
not even a PG word that's not a PG
weren't exactly parental guidance
suggested baby Rick are you kidding this
[Music]
this final mashup nipples in dingleberry
[Music]
I'm not voted why Wow dingleberry I'm
gonna make sure to Justin like this
dingleberries No
I'm refraining further I'm boycotting
what thank you I was nipple I also got
robbed what were you wow
what up racket and so I got shot up
pretty quick I was loggers I think I
crushed it I've been very close to last
if not maybe something you would find in
your bear go go ahead and write the
first thing that comes to mind we'll see
the real bracket title after the answers
are all in oh so it's not actually name
something you'd find your bathroom huh
see said you will will see the actual
bracket title after this so it's a blind
bracket we're just writing something but
it's not gonna be with that much but
you're still supposed to know this is
gonna be it going starting jigs off
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's kind of our we'll probably hit
close to home for a lot of people Oh
oh my god Jesus [ __ ] I don't know Oh
fight I'm gonna be gross dude
I feel bad for everybody whoever the
predicta gonna be close
walk to the cars have so many more germs
okay can't have the clothes home this is
gross dude
oh so you get money based on what
percentage of votes you got - I don't
know that see you don't want to have a
closer we see what's going on on the
other side of fact in the east
I would say hair is very big contact
with yeah so it fit they don't move it
up it mute his mic your mic is muted
[Music]
I don't get how the sci-fi aesthetic
works for this game is done I like I
usually fuss all the time but yeah well
are we talking pre or post toilet paper
I are you the truth the choice is yours
that's why it's on a roller you just
kids using it because if it's if it's
post it's like a new room
before we get on to round 2
it's time to make another prediction
[Music]
we didn't go try predictions right let's
jump back to our bracket for round two
keep in mind this is our dog with what
do you find in your back I think we know
it's cool in here yeah it's pretty close
to home for some people I would imagine
what is going on what I know I was
tampon Dan by the top tampon was a
golden perfect one
he thought I was giving our chances that
they would choose the highroad
grandparents a finalist oh I don't think
like it back and tie this up I mean at
this point wait we this is a pointless
battle you know who's gonna win oh my
god oh oh me the time let's see what
having who has time Wow too close to
call show your support for your answer
you can okay that's pretty cool I said
[ __ ] i I voted for Allah and now we
finally dissociate God so you can see
you in here we're just reading predict
this harder
just don't answer the questions properly
got a Panzers to the audience pander to
the audience who was it what you find in
your bathroom yeah all right I like it I
was blind I think I'm gonna have my fun
poking at my blind this is definitely I
would say maybe the weakest stand out
for the record you watch every single
round here's your shot in cancer can
give any age in years old who knows what
crazy twists and Davin's this bracket
will take what yeah
oh no someone has the same numbers why
don't you guys who guess what number
that is
time's running out
let's see what one of them is trying to
be created turned into by a magic
fortune-telling machine time to get in
those predictions
zones numbers in this wall I was trying
to create but unless Michael Wow someone
did loops yes
boring I feel like after someone else
besides numbers ding she did that just
indefinitely good Jess I'm definitely
doing every different sorry
you're lying time to get it on things
what find out what's it
if you tried timing 69 and I just went
down to 68 I'm not telling you what I'm
doing I think that's what happened uh-uh
it's close enough 1660s yeah wait is
this good this the fact or give it
always be a question asking for a number
let's just see what Rob what did she do
forty
[Music]
[Music]
three gold fetus ghosts
I mean should we cancel this probably
let's see what chat should we cancel it
since then try out the last is it two
more a lot of them someone picked my
favorite number 98 yeah I don't see this
getting crazy funny the answer is yes
says people all right thanks guys
Mike you want good job Thanks you're the
big winner
guess what mine was big ghetto fetus
that's right nice what's the last one
that's an age doodle drawing one to end
them yeah this one is not good how do
you mean agreed huh oh yeah sorry
look it was fine but you don't end on a
number one
like that's just yeah I mean that's
enough that's for a lot of these like
the survived the internet like the one
that was the funniest like everyone
could like you know all right doing
drawing one drawing long civic doodle do
you all do murals to try to beautify the
city Oh Valley people chatter saying you
got just commit disconnected yeah
because we were doing it of a game so
get ready thank time doing a drawing me
doing a drawing one hopefully this is
good just like the last TKO on little
from last game why
oh shoot hello Oh
but man I suck at drawing oh [ __ ]
I made a butterfly
throwing crews orange the butterfly okay
it's kind of Flowery like a flower
butterfly like flower box ramekin
Justins butterfly the orange tag okay I
think we're ready
okay sweet I'm pressing in Josh Shaw on
the chat Josh well hello all right
welcome to doodle Valley a home of the
world's only complete werewolf skeleton
thank you all for volunteering or
lightly bullied to participate in our
town beautification initiative remember
non volunteers can still make a
difference by joining the audience the
mayor wants to turn all the drab white
walls in the town into colorful
community art projects
isn't that right mr. mayor that's right
Martha that's not my name sir I know
just where to start
hey this mural is already in progress
the City Council was supposed to agree
on what to paint but this is as far as
they got before their 11 month recess my
day if you started something you'll
finished it we believe in a little thing
called democracy around here so I'll let
two of you make additions to the drawing
and your fellow volunteers will vote on
who made it better okay Robert and I'm
keeping you on a shorter timer to make
sure you don't over think it oh yeah we
wait well these two are drawing the rest
of you can express my feelings about
their work with the buttons on your
device I like the vegetable one owes it
live oh nice
[Music]
what on earth is the lie may not know
art but I know what I like and I like
both of these sadly only one can win
come on why don't you and I would never
forget our audience voters almost
results that's so fast Mary Beth each
match I'll be picking an emoticon that
tickles my fancy what is ever not a
bonus to the one that got the most of
them this time the bonus goes to the
drawing with the most cards trying to be
up like the resourcing fantastic I was
you know let's see what you I suck it
way better
oh no I couldn't take up so much space
[Music]
[Music]
no panic move okay at least the one the
right has one thing I can identify the
people have spoken
[Music]
[Music]
Wow add in the audience audience Wow
that's weird
up next cuz you're colored in a to go I
didn't come out I did that I just got
this son Anna
[Music]
especially at this point I don't like
that you have to add on to it
yeah I don't like I get the add-on
because the problem so much space dark
air air
as a must in the purple mustache and an
umbrella hat the problem of this one too
is that like I think so I don't think I
would have drawn so much the first round
exactly do it again will seem like okay
tone Ahmad I look back and the audience
Wow
this is only match up 583 more we have
to go over again I don't see you're
gonna eventually have to go there's a
while
[Music]
I don't know time to vote I like that
there's a story I just made that up
felt like you're inspired
it's like moment of truth is oats in I
was down the wire it should be it should
be like it should be more new drawings
that you come back like that you know I
mean like to Google can swear it square
off and keep coming back it is a very
short amount of time
[Music]
what is that a little bit you're right
really what oh you're gonna race damn it
try to make balls cutting a cigarette in
TV I'm sure I dare you wild mustache
you're gonna race that's a game show
here we go
that's a game changer but only for York
not for Oh congratulations
I just added a mustache yeah does good
move good stuff next OSH go
there's two more yeah I really just
overdid it first drive question mark
behind
Oh Benson flavor it's voting time rack
up those votes plus the audience so he
just needs to like blackout next on deck
I don't think your pen is big enough yo
you can adjust the oh yeah there it is
[Music]
okay maybe not
Eric tan back here that hole with that
we might need to swap out say what his
mics down q-max down you can go go do it
I come in there welcome to sit down
enjoying this fantastic I mean maybe
that's what you're supposed to do
he's like actually the Internet the
internet one was the best
I think I think we'll go back in mmm hey
Joey
hello but they use our device to suggest
one anymore
oh it's suggest a title for this I got
an idea
penis
[Music]
I feel like every match would evolvement
[Music]
but like you'd have a speak stew you
Onis well you know most drawing games do
end and the audience know it was a
variety of dress Wow
we drove out of our building it was a
date there but coconuts that had fallen
down oh wow that's just round one
that's not back out get out of your dog
wait okay okay
whew quick back to the good game I know
the good business minutes left that was
[Music]
derive the Internet um I think this is a
an interesting addition to the party
pack Jamboree everyone is everyone is
everyone got think you said it earlier
like they all got one like great game I
feel like the rest are borderline I
thought like party fact three had a few
really good ones like I really like
faking it faking is really great
it requires everyone to know like just
be aware of what's going on but so like
once everyone's on the same page
it's just like yeah that's really fun I
think guess be nage is it going to is
that that's a polling one no undermined
it is faking it you're right okay and
fij is always solid it I think yes Rock
the internet it myself I'm sorry
[Music]
yep Rinne everyone's in we're good
gameplay here we go all right this is
fun
so we're yeah we're gonna end on this
this has been Jack's box looks like my
dad owes me and join the audience at any
time because here we go more personal
but apparently is actually a good one
for streaming and there's a new mode for
vintage which yeah yeah we shouldn't try
it
hey I'm just like yeah it's like those
shoes me next more personal sorts about
people in the ruins rather than doing
tutorials here to teach you how to play
survive the internet so in each round
you'll get a prompt on your device the
objective is to twist these words okay
let's get into it let's turn things on
uh ecommerce site foolís or online store
you should be seeing a prompt on your
controller there are no wrong answers so
just answer honestly
I really kind like I try to think of
answers that if my mom were watching she
would still be very except she would be
like oh yeah I'm glad this is my son's
job this is what he does for a living
I'm proud of them I try to make my
entire family do everything that I
[Music]
I think this is gonna be a go on yeah
another players comment has been sent to
your device was their words the funniest
way possible
[Music]
[Music]
all the wrongdoing Gucci Mane
[Music]
I
oh well here goes nothing
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
one star
why
[Laughter]
that is that is surprising that's a good
one
that's an owner right that's like going
with also accurate
which of these made you laugh the
hardest
[Music]
it was it asked me to describe my
favorite shirt let's see what the
audience I was the one that had to write
that to stare fine who kid that was a
hard one to come up with something for
them I think something think of
something awesome and you the big target
cards the whole supporting you guys
that was good oh thank you thank you see
that makes you the horrible no great
let's go to a social networking site
this go ahead and be Candice this is our
safe space
mine says what's your opinion of people
who take showers at night
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] target so when you answer it says
thanks the internet needed Europe
[Music]
he's gone I hope this inspires you take
this quote out of context so it makes
its author look ridiculous
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's go is brought to you by
ghostbusters yeah fun is really long I
can't my breathing's dead right now
[Music]
my bonus is anyone else my playmate
Rob use your laptop yeah you know like
it's too late now I'm worried logging
here
[Music]
oh right like what time should I drop
her off
[Laughter]
[Music]
I could not
somebody you named Justin
[Music]
I feel like it should be the other way
around yeah but maybe maybe a size
creative it depends on what they're
calling it
yeah vote for the comment you think
looks the most absurd
[Music]
that's one of the somebody in the users
also name is isn't it just
I'm JK it was also at Justin
[Music]
let's see how everybody voted what
oh my
[Music]
holy mackerel best
taking up the salal that shovel the
leaderboard let's find out there's only
three rounds for this right yeah though
because there is not a lot of a balloon
for this lot let's eat this party train
moving go to another problem
I'd like you to really listen to your
heart this time oh my sighs what's your
favorite bad word mine's only
unfortunate cookers
[Music]
20 seconds
[Music]
this is the last one I think so last
[ __ ] it does I I'm used to autocorrect
helping you alright you know the drill
[Music]
[Music]
until that I got a meatball yeah I got a
meatball pitch to me so I think let's
see what you Rascals came up with
[Music]
[Laughter]
Oh God
[Music]
Rob Wow
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
Oh Tommy in the chest is I think there
isn't the last one always a photo there
the photo on oh let's get those boats in
[Music]
at the bottom yeah I know
okay here are the verdicts overwhelming
[Music]
hey you got played son Justin Justin not
shall we
are you sure just the CC in second place
the points are worth double this round
so anything can happen
okay I hope you have one last opinion in
you know be the same picture I do it's
time to take the gloves off really go
for it this time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
25 seconds
[Music]
[Music]
Justin RJ that's a good I just wanted to
make sure that it
[Music]
hello Christopher
hashtag tasty
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
we do such a thing
oh that was good no you have to get
upset tase off-camera upset yeah like I
like that last one
I got creative
[Music]
usual people think yeah laugh out loud
nice nice
well that's embarrassing I'd be nice one
John Luke I'd be no fake Justin than
grant well that was good no son that was
the winner it was blue the last game was
the winner for sure the most laughs to
be had
Abdullah that was jack box party tech 4
comes out for that 4.5 4
you'll comes out October 17th I believe
it starts coming out on October 17th
yeah this is gonna be on psi October
17th PlayStation 4 18s Apple TV if you
have one 19th is Nintendo switch and
20th you can get this on Xbox one
um I think there's also PC and Mac right
yeah it is oh and nipple t-bill i like
your focus was Apple TV Oh am PC Apple
TV is the 18th that gets its own day
here anyway anyways that was fun I liked
that last game the most smooth not so
much
we have to go try the dating one at some
point yeah definitely
regardless we're gonna start a party
this is where it's at
everyone's got one of these yeah what
these things I had to borrow one but I
really want to buy one now and like I
feel like this is super useful this is
like the best controller I really want
to go out and buy a phone all right
thank you guys so much for hanging with
us on the live chat here and I believe
that what's the price - I believe it's
like $24 I believe is what I saw that's
that's right yeah less than 100 yes less
than $100 this may be the scream again
thank you guys very much and see you
next time happy Friday the 13th the 13
fish Baker
[Music]